welcome to this video playing a
five-minute game and somehow my
recording software acting weird again I
lost a couple of seconds yet okay
go go with these six hmm yeah that's
just prepare a five and after d5 I need
to take on the two
but I'm in a way threatening Bishop d2
now yeah I guess he needed to do that
right so grab here and go to e7 yeah I
can't remove that so just two castles
right my heart so he's going for
tweaking a phone but I have a Bishop f5
now the night is nice only 7 yeah this
is I am here from the Netherlands that's
let's check briefly how would he do he's
a former dutch champion he wanted in the
the 80s almighty's quite a while ago a
very strong tournament back then it was
solution upset and he he already he also
had beat me in the in the Dutch team
competition a couple of years ago really
badly
I remember that act didn't didn't fell
so hot after this game all right
what now I'm up here okay I need to
exchange the question however is is this
a threat yeah it is probably something
to to look at maybe rook e8 it's an idea
so that after Bishop f6 a plane Knight
takes d5 yeah maybe if it goes Bishop to
e5 then I can I can move the knight to
somewhere b6 or so and then take next
so be sure f6 I go Knight takes d5 hmm
yeah I hope this is really working
alright seems at least he believed me so
on yeah maybe here I'm tweaking on the
on the e-file this is important yeah but
I have the e phone so it's it's not a
big deal
this is doubling of pawns
ninety-four
I want to go to C to C to D for
something like that
check least I'm not behind on the clock
for once okay how to do this now so I
got good control here the night prevents
rookie three and I have looked to a
night to deform at the moment
ninety-four answered by mukki threesome
this wasn't wasn't too great
check
I want to try to get this play against
the queenside
night before
he needs to weaken the queenside
even more
I thought that night to see five what
would help me and I have night see to 34
this is an important tactical idea 94-92
to deform go here take on b3 you can
take here this check yeah it's not
helping I came to do that check
so probably back and that's it for also
check up for the taking
maybe maybe you should have gone to some
on the square I don't know who came it's
an equal material and I got the apron
yeah f60 to allow really
95 the idea taking c4g home hmm
still I need to be cautious
I take 95 g5 and taking takes e4 and f6
check
it's not not entirely clear he's not
clear to me check-check
the ebon should decide really yeah I can
take I know I need to I need to push
first make him go back 93 now must go
there yeah man I'm winning on time
oh maybe disconnected I hope it's not my
client it's perfect on time yeah yeah
maybe I don't know it's not an unfair
play or something probably it's a real
connection issue yeah I know it is it is
it is gone you're the pawn promotes yeah
hmm yeah tricky we attract the endgame I
don't think what should lose here but
okay with less time it can easily easily
happen whether complexly gives white a
big edge here this I find really
surprising I should watch you better
yeah I've got an ad outside passport
okay it is it is blocked at the moment
by the night but still strange yeah
somewhere on ta probably needs to
improve nightmoon's probably
yeah I wonder about the middle gamers
level system I thought this should be
really good for black with the file and
so on but it's shiny this is not not
leading to much really hmm justing yeah
interesting game I hope you liked it
thanks for watching